welcome to the recruitment roller
coaster podcast my name's
hisham azuz today i'm very excited to be
joined by
the lovely michelle flynn who has
worked in recruitment for over 20 years
but for the last 18 months has been
supporting
recruiters with their health and
well-being to help them bring
more balance across their life michelle
thank you for uh joining me
well thank you very much for inviting me
along i'd like to think that
whoever's listening to this should know
who you are and if they don't i'm
excited for them to find out a lot more
about you and what you've been up to in
the journey that you've been on
um but as we were discussing before we
started
i think today we're definitely gonna
talk about michelle flynn
and you being a recruiter for a pretty
long time
and we're gonna talk about that but um i
think
what i love about your story is how yeah
how you segwayed or taken your own
journey and story
um and turned that into something that
you want to make sure other people don't
go through and and help other people
with
and it's always interesting because
there's a few people that have gone
through
um a journey like yours that have
changed sort of what they do et cetera
but recruitment's always ended up really
helping them
which i always like right if that's
build relationships or the people you
end up working with or whatever i think
it's
um yeah i love that about recruitment
how it always ends up
serving you it seems like even though
you turn into a health coach or a health
and well-being coach right
without a doubt so why don't we start
them with um
so obviously you you worked for
creighton from wrong
big infamous s3
i did i was at computer futures for
eight and a half years
so basically all of my 20s wow that's
crazy and what so where
what year did you join them
oh 1997. really i joined them
and um and i stayed there all the way
through to 2005.
wow years old when you uh
oh my goodness
oh my goodness how old do i feel
why don't we start there because i've
had the number of people from
er always seems to be xs3 because
there's so many people that left and
started their own business but i'd love
to hear from and i'll be honest
i think pretty much most of the people
i've had on have been
um male right that was in the s3
world so what how would you describe
the culture there um
i look back at it so so fondly um
it was just amazing what a place for me
to go and learn how to recruit
um to be honest i had no intention of
getting into recruitment i have got a
maths degree
and i went to a graduate recruitment
agency to look for a job
and they said oh forget maths have you
thought about doing recruitment i was
like
no what's that and they said well you
can earn a lot of money
sounds good and then somehow managed to
get myself a job at computer futures
which i still don't really understand
how because i remember
walking in for an interview with simon
arbor who was sort of one of the
original founders
and i fell over um the rug in front of
his desk and almost landed on his desk
and just i look back at the interviews
with sort of
almost embarrassment but somehow managed
to get the job
and um when they were expecting me to
start picking the phone up i was like
what do you mean pick the phone up
i just had no idea um but it turned out
i was really good at it
and um i think it was my sort of sheer
determination
my my drive to sort of earn a lot of
money
um i worked the permanent market so um
i mainly did pc support and then moved
through sort of various other markets
but pc support was very much kind of
my baby um and i just i loved every
minute of it i would not be where i am
today without everything that i learned
there the um
sort of work attitude um
sort of the fact that you were not late
the fact that
sort of um even down to so you didn't
leave dirty dishes on the side in the
kitchen you put them in the dishwasher
it was sort of
um such an amazing training ground and
to this day i've got sort of some of my
best friends and people that i met at
computer futures and
um i now have a lot of joy working with
a lot of people
um who are sort of xs3 so i feel very
very grateful
well what do you think what do you think
may
sort of made up the sort of special
ingredients of their culture do you
think
looking back would you say um
the leadership was amazing um the people
sort of from bill and simon who founded
it through to
um sort of the people that i work
closely with so whether that was
russell clements gary goldsmith daley
thompson
down to my manager lucy gilmore um just
absolutely inspiring people um
it was a you were just completely in the
right environment to succeed they were
they were very particular about who they
hired
so by getting through the door in the
first place you're already
sort of well on your way to success but
um
it felt like a family i was in my
twenties
living in a flat share and um absolutely
knew that they would look after me
and if i needed them uh any time day or
night that they would have been there so
they were really people focused um
and they drove us really hard i'm not
saying it was easy
but that has given me absolutely the
sort of the drive that i've got now to
sort of
uh succeed in whatever it is that i'm
doing yeah i've heard that a lot that
the standards were very high and
yeah the bar was always high and people
that were in that culture
had to aspire to be that and more um
what what so back then thinking about
your
physical mental health what where was
you were
with that person you'll see it was all
your 20s like what i don't know what was
that like
for you like was that impressive
but would you say like looking back you
was in a good mental physical place
or because obviously now i'm sure the
journey you've been on and the
self-discovery and stuff
i don't know is that was it a pretty
good couple
obviously eight years or so or looking
back on that how was that
looking back my diet was shocking um
i'm not a big cook and i used to get off
at the tube
um where i lived in southgate i'd get
off the tube and i'd go to the kebab
shop opposite the tube
i'd walk in they'd say the usual
um and i would have pita bread with
tamari salata and salad
for dinner pretty much every night of
the week eat it
on the walk to my flat and throw the
container in the outside bin so i didn't
have to do any washing
um when i sold my flat after 10 years
they thought i'd put a new kitchen in
because i should not use the kitchen so
i look back and
i was never into exercise i tried the
gym and
i'd sort of there was some real gym
bunnies in the office as a
one of the ladies belle wilson was in
the gym all the time and i tried to be
motivated and
i think like sort of a lot of people i'd
get excited go for a bit and then
not go again so i look back and um
i don't really know how i actually sort
of
wasn't more ill but yeah i don't know i
i ever took a day off sick but i think
that was um
probably due to sort of my mental
resilience at that point which i can
look back now
and see that i had really strong
resilience but it wasn't talked about
back then sort of 20 years ago
resilience was something they just
talked about in the military whereas
now it's become something that's kind of
um so
important particularly in recruitment
yeah so yeah
i think um i just find that interesting
isn't it because i think it's like
michelle a 20 year old because obviously
you being
older right i think it's easy to look
back but when you're a 20 year old you
do think you're invincible right in
terms of like oh i'll think about that
when i'm 30 or whatever and i just find
that interesting right
but i think sort of the journey that
i've been on and what i've
tried to cultivate for myself but have
good months bad days
is um if you don't do it now or you
don't try and cultivate habits that are
going to serve you for the long term and
make sure that your life is more
sustainable
when you are in your 20s and maybe more
fit healthy it's going to be even more
difficult when you decide to change that
when you're older
without a doubt that's what i mean i
wish i knew back then what i know now
um i think that sort of weight was
always something that um
i i was never sort of i was always
slightly overweight
and um not to the point of it being a
massive
problem but always slightly overweight
sort of
ate too many crisps and the sandwich man
would come in at
10 and a half 10 and i'd get a smoked
salmon cream cheese bagel and a
can of coke and a packet of crisps as a
snack and then i'd have my lunch
um so sort of i really wish i had
i could go back because i think what the
one thing i wish i had found in my
twenties was yoga
really yeah i absolutely love it and um
i'm 44 now
and i'm getting better at it but i think
if i heard i've had an extra 20 years of
practice
i might actually be able to do a
handstand by now
and yeah anyone listening that thinks
yoga is easy
it's not like anyone honestly
it's not it's so difficult it's a
journey in itself
it's unbelievably hard like i show
people my yoga instructors instagram
accounts and
they just can't believe it i'm like if
you think yoga is just sitting on the
floor it's like
it's not yeah yeah i think i just find
that really interesting right because i
think and this is probably
because some of the conversations you
have now right because i so like
when you're in this office culture so i
was so i was in when i was in
recruitment i was in an office of eight
people
and that's obviously the culture was
obviously really small and i was the
weird guy in the office right and what i
mean by that is
i was a wig like the office that ate a
raw avocado
every single lunch time with a spoon i
was the guy with the vegetable
smoothie you know what i mean and like
and the thing is
but what i'm getting at is that like why
is it
that it takes so much for us to break
what we normally do or the habits that
we get into right because
every single day or 75 of the time
my colleagues would go and get a meal
deal for lunch
and at three o'clock they would all say
i feel [ __ ]
i don't feel great i don't feel
energized but
you do it every single day do you know
what i mean and you'll just it should
and but
i've been there right and i i found that
so easy when i was in
lockdown there was just a couple of
times where i thought oh you know what
i'm gonna have a cheese and pickle
sandwich and then
i felt [ __ ] but i still i i would find
myself doing it
four days straight like heisha what the
[ __ ] you doing like you're just gonna
moan about it but
i find that so interesting right because
you did that for that whole period and
there's
there was nothing that encouraged you to
break that
you may not even thought about breaking
it but i think so many people go through
that
so many people they i think that's i
find that so interesting
i did a talk probably about a year ago
now for a recruitment business
and i do a talk about what you actually
need to know to be healthy
and as i came out i overheard two girls
talking one of the girls said
i know all of that already and the other
girl said yeah but you're not doing any
of them
which i thought was just brilliant but
the whole point is it's not rocket
science like
the summary of that talk when i kind of
get to the final slide it's like what
you actually need to know is
eat real food move a bit sleep a bit
more and breathe properly
and maybe have a hug you're like it's
not difficult and yet
i think there's too much information so
people just are so overwhelmed
they just don't bother yeah yeah when
you're in your
20s like you said you just think oh it's
such a long way off i won't worry about
it that's what i mean it's that and
i think we do we obviously the way that
we're wired and how we work as human
beings it's so easy to just
do things on repeat and get comfortable
with what we do and all these things but
no yeah i think with the whole food
thing um
it's yeah i think everyone from always
the conversations i've had
everyone a lot of people are looking for
that silver bullet right it's like right
what can i eat that's going to
make me lose weight quicker or whatever
um
but it's not rocky should i tell you
what the answer is
vegetables yeah vegetables yeah
vegetables yeah and i think um what
yeah and it's just like simple maths is
you eat less calories than your
body requires to lose weight
that's how you that's how you lose
weight and then it's like okay well what
makes up those
calories but i think it's just an
interesting one that i think because i
think in that of it in the office
culture
there's that like you always hear that
that just i feel [ __ ] i feel [ __ ] off
that lunch
but you'll see it you just hear it every
single day
yeah it's so so true and we used to sort
of i mentioned bel wilson earlier she
was amazing
so going to the gym and we'd look at her
lunches and she'd be eating salads with
beans and
all of these grains and you'd look and
go what are you eating
and now i look and i'm like oh what why
did why did i
because i think part part of the part
that's hard as well i always speak to my
mom about this because she she loves to
cook and
so she works at sainsbury's and she'll
go to the lunch room with some like
interesting meal and when you're not the
person that's
eating the normal stuff you get more
comments
you get more people going michelle what
are you what's that you eating and you
get more attention
so like even when you try and do
something about it you draw more
attention to yourself
rather than if you just went and grabbed
the meal deal that that's that's always
an interesting part of it as well i
think
okay yeah so i think that's that's
interesting to it as well but um
so why why don't we um why don't you
talk a bit about sort of your journey
then
obviously spoke about s3 what you went
on and
so what catapulted you into or what was
the catalyst
to you getting to the point where you're
now helping recruiters with
health well-being etc okay so yeah
i left s3 um i went traveling the world
went to kind of
find myself which um to be honest i did
i remember um i'm going to name him vas
constanti who is my contract counterpart
i love us
um i remember when i got back he was
like oh my god you're so much nicer
really thanks yeah what are you trying
to say but i was sort of
very single focused when i was sort of
at computer futures
um i then went and became the in-house
recruitment manager for one of my
clients
and then that led to me setting up my
own little in-house recruitment business
which was
going brilliantly well working with
companies like moon pig the financial
times huddle
seven digital a lot of tech startups um
and then about six years ago
i woke up one morning and i thought i
was having a heart attack um
i collapsed onto the floor my husband
called the ambulance
i remember they'd obviously asked him to
count my breathing so they're obviously
trying to work out was actually still
alive so how quickly it's in the
ambulance
um so i remember hearing him count then
the paramedics turned up
um they were absolutely amazing
fortunately it wasn't a heart attack
but for a period of three years
following that i just kept getting sick
all the time
so every month for about a week i'd get
the flu
i could get away with sort of running my
business because i was good at
recruitment my
clients were happy with what i was doing
i could work from home
um if i needed to but i was also
exhausted
so at three o'clock every day no matter
where i was i'd disappear off to a
toilet put the toilet seat down have a
little power nap
i just thought that was normal yeah
you're back now just
like it's a quick one on this like i
think that's an interesting part of this
because i
like again with like the being ill thing
i think a lot of people can just think
oh yeah
i get it a couple of times a year that's
that's not like that's normal
i think i don't know i think that i find
that so like a new part of you thought
well yeah this is normal i just get it
all a couple of times a month and
so people can fall into that can't they
and i was completely and it was only i
remember one of the clients
um was working on site at moon pig and
got on amazingly well with the teams and
i'd become quite good friends with one
of the the developers and i remember him
making a bit of a joke one morning he
was like oh you sick again
and i was a bit like what i'm never sick
and he was like oh no you're always sick
and i was just
mortified um like i knew i was doing the
naps and i was also gaining weight and i
knew i was gaining weight but i was in
my 40s at this point so i was like well
women in their 40s that's what happens
um
but again it was just sort of like i
just got used to it and i think that
we all get so used to whether it's
feeling bloated feeling tired
feeling like gluten memory loss you kind
of go oh why is i can't remember those
things anymore
it just you assume that that's what
comes with age
um and then i was found collapsed again
kind of um
got picked up off the bathroom floor
massive black eye and it was like
okay this is enough this is not right so
i started working with a health coach
um i completely thought she was going to
talk to me about food because
i was gaining weight so surely the
solution is food
and she didn't she talked to me about
stress how stress impacts the body
how basically our hormones change to
deal with stress
and as soon as she explained it all i
just felt like such a
relief because finally i had an answer
because when you're stressed
your immune system doesn't function your
metabolism doesn't function
your energy levels your sleep your sex
drive like
your clarity of thought your memory
nothing works
so i was like wow okay and then i just
went on this whole journey of sort of
um self-improvement sounded cheesy
yeah it was that so it's like what do i
need to change what do i need to change
with my food
with my exercise i was actually over
exercising i've become sort of a real
fan of
high intensity boot camps and kind of
half marathons and
actually they don't work for me um so i
had all of these
personal kind of um changes happening
and i was just feeling so
empowered that i decided to study
because i thought
how do i keep this going because most
things are like a fad you do it for a
while and then you just go back
i've done that throughout my life i
tried every different diet
so i thought i'd study it so i started a
year-long course
i had no intention of doing anything
with it happy doing my recruitment
self-education
self-education kind of
self-accountability
and then people started to say to me oh
you look different
i was losing weight so i looked
noticeably different but also
i had this sort of almost annoying new
energy i wasn't getting sick
um and before i knew it i was doing
one-to-one coaching with people
and then um i can't remember who i
actually did my first talk for but um
i got asked to do a corporate talk and
um it just spiraled from there and
i'll be honest i didn't plan to sort of
um
really specialize in recruitment but it
became so obvious that the people that i
understand most
the lifestyle that i understand the most
is recruitment
and where is sort of one of the
industries where people
have the most pressure the longest hours
maybe not necessarily the healthiest
lifestyles
it's recruitment um so i don't work
solely with recruiters but about 90
of my clients are recruitment businesses
um
and i i love it i'm very honored a
couple of things
before i'd love to sort of i'd love for
us to talk about
the common things that you've ended up
speaking to people about the common
things that you've seen and but
two things so the first thing because
i've done my sort of own self-education
on this but it'd be great
just for you to talk because i think a
lot of people go through
that confusion of do you know you said
you had that sort of moment of
realization around stress and how that's
related with the body and stuff
i guess it'd be good if you could just i
know you just mentioned it there how it
affects all parts of the body but
in like layman's terms like what is the
most important thing that we just need
to understand about the relationship
with stress and our body and why that
impacts everything i think that'd be
good
just because that's obviously the
understanding you went through that made
you realize
a lot of things like how would you sort
of talk about that or describe that
yeah so they the stat is that sort of
and that's probably a bit different at
the moment giving covid but before kovid
the stat was 75 to 90 of visits to the
doctor were in some way related to
stress
so i had the flu which i just assumed
was the flu but it was actually stress
related
so what happens is when our bodies go
into a state of stress the way that they
react is that they are trying to protect
us from danger
now they see danger as being chased by a
tiger like it was in the day of the
caveman
our bodies are still the same so it
thinks there's a tiger coming
so we can either run from the tiger or
we can
um get killed by the tiger all right um
so the whole point is stress is meant to
be short-lived it's it's not meant to be
chronic it's not meant to be something
that we are dealing with from the minute
the alarm goes off in the morning
through to
sort of the news social media work
pressures finance pressures child
pressures etc etc
um so when we are in a state of stress
our
adrenaline and our cortisol which are
our stress hormones increase
to prepare our body to basically run
from a tiger
so what happens all of the blood and all
of the oxygen leaves the center of our
body which is where our organs are to go
to our hands and our feet to run
so our organs in our brain don't have
the oxygen or the blood that they need
to function properly
but also what happens is our body wants
fast burn
fuel so for anyone who craves sugar or
alcohol when they're stressed
this is why fast burn fuel is glucose
which is sugar
so our body is burning all the sugar in
our body um
to give us this energy to run from the
tiger and because our bodies are clever
if you imagine this is your tank of
sugar
when your tank goes down your body sends
a craving to your brain
i need to quickly fill it up yeah yeah
so anyone who says to me they've got a
craving for sugar
i don't talk to them about dairy milk or
bottle of pinot grigio
i'll talk to them about stress so
ultimately
our bodies go into absolute protection
mode
which means our immune system doesn't
function so the immune system yeah
not worrying about a cold our metabolism
not worrying about losing weight
our clarity of thought doesn't all of
those things just basically get
put over here because the number one
function our body has to do is protect
ourselves from danger
and that's why unless you have um like
you break your leg which is an obvious
sort of trauma
if you have anything else that's wrong
it is probably in some way related to
stress because
stress stops you sleeping and when you
don't sleep properly you get sick
stress can stop you making the right
food choices when you make poor food
choices
you can get sick so it's all the body is
the whole
connection of cogs and um when when
they're all working properly brilliant
but when something is out of place
your body just stops functioning
properly no yeah you know you explain
that
really well and clearly that's that's
awesome and obviously a big part of that
is that
obviously the the most evolved part of
our brain is that function isn't it the
sort of that's made us survive and help
us get but it
it's obviously that's the thing isn't it
like being in that constant state of
stress all day when as you said there is
no animal to run away from or whatever
that's
that that's just crazy that is bad
yeah and in recruitment they kind of get
referred to as micro stress doses
in recruitment every time that phone
rings and it's a client who's trying to
sort of negotiate down on fees or a
candidate who doesn't want to take the
job offer or
you're doing some bd and you can't get
through to anyone you are being hit by
micro stress doses constantly
so the chances are if you had your heart
rate
measured and your stress measured over a
period of 24 hours
you would find that you would be in a
state of stress for a large proportion
of that
and the scariest thing is and in my case
i had no idea
no idea at all i was stressed and that's
i think the scariest thing
is that a lot of people say no i'm not
stressed
and i i talk to people so often they're
like i've got this challenge with one of
my team but i'm fine
and then by the end of the call they're
like oh i'm not okay am i
we all suffer with stress it's just
about
the ability to then deal with it i think
it's
yeah and i'm keen to talk about that but
but i think it's
when you say the word stress i'm
stressed
it's a lot of people will associate how
different things i feel like
some people will think yeah that's part
of working hard
i'm stressed yeah that's part of working
hard and then some people
will deem like that person that might be
saying no i'm michelle i'm not stressed
because the edema is a real negative or
a bad thing right
or only deem stress as when it's like
really bad right yeah so like i guess
how like what how do we need to get
what's what should our relationship do
with stress you know what like what's a
more
yeah i guess because i think it's good
to have a better understanding of that i
think people
people have a better understanding of
what being stressed means or what
actually
stress is i think that can help people
understand or give them a better chance
of overcoming prevention etc
yeah and we all need stress stress is a
completely natural thing
it's something that our body is prepared
for and um
that's absolutely fine the challenge is
we've got used to these high level and
some people now
actually get off on feeling stressed so
that high adrenaline feeling that rush
that they get that heart rate that kind
of like
um you're about to close the deal
feeling that's exciting when you're
about to close a deal but people almost
get obsessed with that feeling so
suddenly they're introducing
things in their life so whether that's
they like high endurance sport or
whether it's
maybe that they're not eating the right
food because that makes their bodies
feel that sort of
high fast heart rate so people almost
get off on the feeling of being stressed
so
i think firstly it's like stress is as
it's meant to be
a positive thing it protects us
and a bit of stress throughout the day
to keep you on track
a bit of adrenaline pumping when you're
about to deliver another
candidate absolutely no problem at all
um it's the same sort of stress causes
inflammation in the body and again
inflammation in the body is a natural
thing it's meant to happen
if you bang your finger and you get
inflammation to protect your finger till
it repairs
that's a natural thing but it's when you
are inflamed
basically yeah yeah
so it's it's differentiating and
noticing
the symptoms of when you start to notice
chronic
stress so suddenly that this constant
sense of urgency about everything
the ability not to sleep um the um
not wanting to go to work not wanting to
socialize feeling a bit
paranoid um starting to look at those
things and go
that's not actually normal to feel like
that
that's something that there are ways to
manage that so that you don't
have those symptoms that um would be
seen as sort of uncomfortable symptoms
yeah so that that's what i'd love to
talk about now michelle about so
what what people can do good habits they
can try and instill that can help
prevention because i think what we're
talking about here is look stress is
there it exists
it has its positives but when it's when
you're stressed all the time
you've spoken about the things that that
can cause that's when
you can end up on the floor with a black
eye right all of a sudden
and i think this links to the other
thing that i wanted to sort of talk to
you about because it
it's so common from the podcast and the
people that i listened to the people
that i had on this
show is like why is it that it sometimes
takes a real
low moment or a bad thing to happen for
us to take
action or for us to change things right
it took you twice
being found on the floor for you to be
like i'm i'm changing this do you know
what i mean i think
that's part of it so i guess um yeah
what is
what are the sort of common things that
you speak to people about in terms of
that can help the prevention of getting
to that
because i think that's what that's what
hopefully i i'm from what i understand
it's
that's a big part of what you're trying
to prevent for people so they don't find
themselves on the floor being
woken up by a um paramedic right so
what absolutely yes it's like what are
the common
things that you end up finding yourself
speaking to people about to help
prevent yeah to prevent getting to those
moments
i think i think you're completely right
and just sort of a bit of a personal
sharing is that my husband's best friend
at age 43
um died for so nearly four years ago now
absolutely lifestyle related um
food maybe what he was drinking
stress he had a high stress job and it
is your point
why is it that we all wait for something
really bad to happen before we actually
decide to make a change and
i'm one of the lucky ones i was able to
make the change
simon however was not so lucky um he
didn't get that second chance and
i think we all have to restart taking it
seriously and
there's so many different things that
can impact different people but
the first thing you've got to be looking
at is sort of what you're eating
it's like let's look back to kind of the
philosophers of thousands of years ago
they knew what they were talking about
food is medicine you are what you eat
all of these things that we've heard
before if you are filling your body with
processed foods refined sugars sort of
cheap
fats cheap meats um it goes into your
guts
it basically upsets your gut which is
where your immune system is
your gut talks to your brain sort of
food
and mental health is directly linked so
so often people are talking to me about
what they should eat people are often
maybe not quite as honest with
themselves about what they eat so i love
doing food diaries with people because
they think that they really well and
then we realize they eat one vegetable a
day
um so the first thing is definitely
trying to get people eating
more vegetables and i think just just on
that point just from what i've always
so i went so i was um i was vegan for
like two and a half years
and um and then now i'm not
but i think what i always try to
whenever i speak to people about food
and stuff for me my stance on it is like
what works for you michelle isn't gonna
work for me
i think that's just such an important
insight because
we can find ourselves on the search for
the perfect vegetable that
can help us lose weight or whatever but
it's just really important to
actually work out what works for you and
that might not be that might not work or
what you've seen on instagram or what
you've read
i think that's where the problem could
be sometimes isn't it and
how you're made up and your dna is
totally different to mine so
there is an element of experimenting and
finding out what works for you and you
have to listen to your body
like yeah when when i first went vegan
it really worked for me but then towards
the end
i was bloated all the time um i was fine
a lot of the time
um way too many people yeah in too many
beans i
ate falafels way too often and i was
like
and i've sort of and i don't know if you
ever come across this but i sort of got
i got a bit tribal with being vegan and
i was i sort of caught myself actually
have i
sort of am i vegan now just because i
want to say i'm vegan rather than
actually listen to my body and
sort of wanting to eat stuff that leaves
me energizing stuff and i think that's
really important to
understand is like what works for you
isn't going to work for the next person
what you read may not work for you and
that's okay you've got to work it out
yeah your body is your best doctor your
body knows what it wants and
i've actually so i'm plant-based rather
than vegan
um and for me i absolutely love it
um i've never felt more empowered um
to make food choices that's not to say
that i don't have a pizza
or maybe the odd bottle of wine of
course i do
but on the whole um i eat really cleanly
and i love it but you're completely
right i
i don't preach that to any of my clients
what i will say is if you're going to
eat animal products
invest in the good quality stuff because
if you're buying
cheap meats um then you're basically
eating all the growth hormones and the
antibiotics and stuff so
absolutely if you want to go and get a
sort of a great organic
chicken enjoy it um
so it's completely about that it's sort
of um
some people are great with dairy other
people are not great with dairy some
people could be gluten other people
aren't
but if your body is bloated or if you're
getting a lot of wind or
you haven't got the energy levels that's
the symptom of your body
trying to talk to you to tell you
something's not right exactly so um
so always always start always start with
food no surprise there
everyone would have had it before
exercise forget the physical benefits of
exercise
the mental benefit of exercise has any
like
how has anyone ever said after exercise
i wish i hadn't done that
yeah no we like and this is what's
hilarious with exercise that excuse of
oh i'm too tired
oh i can't today and yet you all know
that after doing it you'll feel more
energized so
when i'm stood i would be going to
barry's boot camp
um which is one of the world's hardest
workouts supposedly
and um i'd be stood outside it and i'd
be hating every moment didn't want to go
in
i'm not going to enjoy this i'd get in
it i'd definitely not be enjoying it
it's not my natural
sort of territory i'm to be honest quite
rubbish at that sort of stuff
i would come out of that room feeling
like i had just won an olympic gold
medal
so but again with exercise like food
everybody's different
so for me actually high intensity
exercise
didn't work now i do walking and i do
yoga
for other people in recruitment there's
a lot of people do boxing because really
good for kind of stress relief
other people you might get sort of
runners cycle
cyclists i don't care what exercise
people do if the only thing you are
doing
every day is walking ten thousand steps
i'm more than happy with that
so again listen to your body don't
pick an exercise you don't like like
don't set yourself a goal to run a
marathon if you hate running
if you love dancing dance around your
lounge
that's fine if you like cleaning clean
your house that'll burn the calories
so yeah exercise amazing for
your body it gets all the oxygen pumping
your blood pumping
and the more oxygen that we've got going
into our brain amazing for our mental
health
um and how many more do you want i could
go on for hours with these
let's let's just i reckon now let's
definitely do another one
for sure in terms of like so we've got
food we've got exercise
to help with prevention what what else
sort of do you always normally talk to
people about
my number one is breathing
breathing correctly which most of us do
not do
is one of the best things for reducing
stress reducing anxiety
because what it does is that as i've
talked about our stress hormones
increase when we're
protecting ourselves from the tiger by
slowing our breathing down
it sends a message to our brain that we
are no longer in danger
and there's a lot of people who think ah
not breathing
firstly either i already do that or they
hear the term meditation
and they have assumptions around what
that's going to be like
um and it is without a doubt one of the
most powerful things i do a lot of work
with it with a lot of recruiters who
absolutely love it but it's a hard habit
to build
because the first time that you do it
you probably won't find that it works
and to build a habit it's based on
success and if you try something and
you feel like it doesn't work there's
not really any wants to try
try it again but it's absolute science
it's
oxygen and carbon um carbon dioxide it's
the exchange of gases
um the science behind it's all
completely proven
lots of people listening to this may
have heard of wim hof the ice man
he does his breathing method and then
jumps into kind of ice cold lakes and
runs up everest and a pair of shorts so
it's starting to get more of a um
it's more accepting of something outside
maybe the yoga community
um as something that's a really powerful
tool
not only for stress relief but for
sports performance
like you can basically get your body
doing what lance armstrong did but
legally
just through breathing properly so um
you can
improve your sports performance for fit
by 15 you'll get a better night's sleep
you'll
in my case it helped me lose weight so
focus on the breathing yeah and then
what about just as we're on this
um i guess obviously a lot of recruiters
that listen to this
if if i'm having like one of those days
[ __ ] stressed out everything's gone
wrong
any sort of go-to things that you'd like
i don't know anything i think of like
sort of quick things
or just things that could give me a
better chance of getting the better
frame of mind or whatever if i'm having
one of those horrible days i'm feeling
super stressed anything that you always
try and encourage people to do so i
actually get people to write down a calm
list
and what i mean by that is a list of 10
things that actually makes them feel
calm because
they're all different so but if you
don't know like if you're feeling
stressed and you want to feel calm but
you don't know what to do to make
yourself feel calm because
most of us don't you don't think about
ideally
you don't think about it so i make
people physically write it down and that
might be a certain piece of music
it might be a herbal tea it might be
going for a walk around the block
it might be cuddling the dog in the wee
work if you're in a we
work building it might be like sort of i
love to walk barefoot on the grass
so for me it might be i'd step out of
the office and go to the little park
around the corner and take my shoes off
but everyone is different um so it's
actually
thinking about what works for you um
so that you've got that ability when you
do start to feel stressed and
overwhelmed to go
it's like your little tool box of no i
love that it's really practical
yeah but how often have you ever taken a
step back and thought about that what
actually makes me feel
calm and not stressed yeah i love that
that's awesome
we don't think about it and it's so
simple yeah so
write your calm list yeah no honestly i
will that that's great
um so i guess just to tie this together
then
um something i'm always keen to get
people like you to share your thoughts
on so we've spoken about
prevention of getting to like a really
bad place when you're really stressed et
cetera but like
i guess any other sort of advice for
people that can help them
cope better with mental challenges which
you and i both know are
um given to people by working in
recruitment and just just life in
general even more so with everything
that's going on but
um i don't know any any other things
that some people can try and
instill or create habits around that can
really give them the chance of
overcoming those really difficult days
as well yeah
it all starts with the morning all
starts with what you do first thing
if you wake up two minutes before you're
due to be on the stand up or whatever
you're doing first thing the first video
call and you fall out of bed straight to
your laptop
you are not giving yourself the best
chance of the day
and a lot of people are doing it which
is even worse now because we don't have
a commute necessarily
um to separate that out so best advice
first thing in the morning
best thing you do glass of water next
your bed drink it
your body has been dehydrated from the
night rehydrate it
the next thing you can do is either
physically
go outside if that's not possible open
your curtains open the window
get daylight accessing your eyes because
what happens is when the
sunlight hits your retinas it starts a
hormone process which turns off your
melatonin which is your sleep hormone
and it turns on your serotonin which is
your day hormone
so if you're not doing that process
you're already in an uphill battle for
the day because your body is not ready
to actually go
into the day and then there's something
which i actually think is
fantastic for the recruitment industry
there's a lot of research done
and it's called the miracle morning and
they looked into the world's top
ceos the top athletes as to what they do
every morning
and they came up with six things that
pretty much all of them do
if you google the miracle morning you
can find it or hit them i'm sure you if
i send you a link you can put it in the
notes
um but they've come down with six things
and um
now i'm going to test myself so the
first one is some silence
so taking some just breathing time
affirmations which people think that
affirmations are a bit kind of
rubbish if you tell yourself for 20
years that you are rubbish or stupid
you're not successful you're going to
believe it
so if you tell yourself that you are
great you are brilliant you are good at
your job
you're eventually going to believe it
visualization
so visualize what you want to achieve if
you want to be the biggest recruitment
business out there if you want to be the
best contract recruiter out there you
want to be the best
in-house outsource model whatever it is
visualize it
feel it exercise can exercise first
thing in the morning
we've talked about the benefit of
exercise number five
reading read something good for your
brain don't read social media
read something that's an interesting
like i'm reading um
the chimp paradox it's all about how the
brain works i read a couple of pages
that i feel great
and the last one um is scribing or
writing
it's like get stuff out of your head
even if it's just your to-do list or
whatever it is that's sort of whirling
around in your brain get it out on the
paper
if you wake up and you actually only
need to do each of those things for one
minute
if you've got longer brilliant if you've
got one minute in total that is six
minutes
we can all find six minutes in the
morning even those people with kids we
can find six minutes go and hide in the
bathroom whatever it takes
six minutes to start your day off is
building your resilience which is your
coat of armor which is gonna get you
ready for the day ahead with whatever
the world recruitment's gonna throw at
you
yeah i love that and i think also like
you deserve it
like you deserve your own time like and
it's so important to protect that
you know because it was so easy to wake
up and
jump into other people's worlds and see
what other people are doing
and stuff like that and that's that's
always helped me i always make sure and
whenever i can some days i won't but
most the time that
morning time i won't let anything else
in like that's time for me to process
and
have my own time i think it's so
important that you you protect that i
think
and that i love that that's that's
awesome um yeah
okay so as we sort of come towards the
end here there michelle
um how if i'm listening to this
and there's no one talking about
these types of things in my business and
my recruitment business
what what would you do if you know that
you're you are someone that
feels pretty stressed a lot of the time
um and
maybe for the first time i'm hearing
some of the things that can help me
um no one in in my falls or no one in
the business or culture that i'm in uh
sort of encouraging people to um
encourage me with ideas that can help me
or there's no one i can turn to whatever
because i feel like a lot of people
might
be in that position i don't know what
would yours
yeah what i don't know how how can we
get people to
what i don't know what would you say to
people that may feel sort of alone
within their business that they've got
no one to turn to or
speak to get advice or whatever i mean
if you listen to this great but
i don't know because i feel like a lot
of people may know these things that
you're talking about but have no idea
where to
go or turn to yeah where to start and i
completely get that and
particularly in recruitment and
particularly for men
um there's a lot of obviously um press
around men's mental health
and suicide rates and um sort of
they did research around basically the
support networks that men have
and sort of in the 1950s if you asked a
man how many people he would have to
turn to if he was in trouble
he probably would have about five if you
ask a group of men now
most of them will say zero
and it's just sort of
scary and i know so many of my clients
will talk to me about things that
they have never talked to about with
anyone else um
because they know that what we talk
about is in confidence they know that
i'm not going to judge them
having been in recruitment i've probably
seen it all before
so there's not anything that's going to
shock me and i'm not there to judge
anybody i'm just there to trust them
so i would sort of say if you feel
confident enough that you could actually
be the voice in your business because
you're probably not alone in feeling it
so if you
were feeling confident to step up and
put your story out there that would be
amazing um
obviously that's not for everybody and i
appreciate that or
maybe if you've got a good relationship
with with one of the managers or with
someone in hr maybe you could speak to
them
if you still don't feel that that the
great thing is now
recently that sort of has been the
launch of mental health and recruitment
which is um run by an amazing woman
called wanda who's got
a team of ambassadors and champions who
are there kind of
trying to sort of um make it known to
people that
you're not alone we all have mental
health
um some people are just stronger at
dealing with it and
i think by seeing sort of famous people
step
forward so prince harry stepped forward
or sort of
um looking at some of some of the sad
stories that have gone on
of people who have chosen to take their
lives through mental health
um i think the good thing is is that
people are now talking about it more so
um there are resources out there and i
always say to people
just give me a shout forget any money
piece of it it's like
sort of i'm always here to just have a
chat with someone and if i can help them
long term
great if i'm not the right person maybe
i can lead them to the person who is
um but the most important thing is to
not try and do this on your own
talk to someone whether it's a colleague
a family member a friend
we all know that when we get something
off our chest we feel better what's
gonna say
and you feel so much better for it as
well don't you
anyways i've got my own coach just for
that reason because i love it because i
get an hour every week
just to fully talk about me and how
often do we ever get that because
conversations are
naturally two ways how are you i'm fine
how are you i'm fine
anyway as opposed to actually no what's
going on
um so i love it because sort of i've got
my issues that i'm dealing with um that
i need to support with
so i think it is really important to to
get some help
from from someone you trust yeah and i
love that
um okay michelle well what would be your
sort of part and words then
for people obviously people that listen
to his work in recruitment
from someone it could be around i don't
know if i'm someone that
i do find myself being healed quite a
lot or i do feel really stressed
and could be around my mental health i
guess what would be
michelle's part and words to to people
that listen to this
um do you think would help them it is
time to make you a priority
um that we all feel that um everybody
else is more important
whether that's our work whether that's
our family our children
but fundamentally if you don't look
after yourself first
you cannot be strong for anybody else um
and it's the whole you put the oxygen
mask on yourself first on an aeroplane
it's not selfish
to want some time out to
sleep properly exercise eat properly and
be the ripple effect for other people
because if people see you
looking after you and they see you being
so in a recruitment business if you're
the person that is
being the positive kind of shining light
you're going to impact so many other
people but it's got to start with you
i love that amazing michelle i love what
you do thanks for coming on
it's been a pleasure thank you very much